you know the way this Panther team always responds
you expect a real big effort tonight and try to
take advantage of the capitals get that four
check going they get a quick steal bark off
in front keer the SE that's picked up right off
the bench by farari across to oetkin sends it
cross ice lomberg is there gich has a step off
his stick can he track it down he does gich and
stopped by keer yeah that's his did right out
of the Penalty Box and here's the pass goes off
his stick and the puck never stopped rolling and
when he went in on keer keer decided to stay in
his net he could have come out and maybe played
that puck that's a good angle right there so we
remain scoreless here little more than six
minutes gone by leran defenseman Jensen up
ahead for Dow lead pass thrus on the back hand
big save by bosi that flat again again now it's
Bennett flips it over to emman lson Bennett again
the onetime or keer the save lond Del digs free
the rebound keer is down Rodriguez shoots it's
blocked away couple of Chances with the goal
tender down but it stayed out Rodriguez in front
couldn't te it up and out of the box Valenstein
gathers it in gets to the net and bosski the sa
but it's a penalty he'll get edman Larson and
they're going to give him a penalty shot oh wow
and then Valenstein comes out of the Penalty Box
got a step on emman Lars here we go in the penalty
shot for malen Stein against bosski and Sergey
Bovi right there with him shooter allenstein watch
here Bob is just Frozen there he's watching he
don't come as often anymore he's only got 10 goals
this year and four of them are on that power play
38 years old M bkin foring as it poked Away by
Wilson here's sandine the feed oetkin shoots
and he scores Alex oetkin is 11th of the season
and it's one nothing just like we were talking
about all he takes Panthers failed to clear that
puck here's how this play developed goes back to
the point and there's oetkin that's a sweet spot
it's a knuckler boski gets a piece of it but not
enough look at that a wounded duck and those
are tough to stop lead pass kachuck plays it
down the board zlad gets in after it against
Jensen good hit by eblad stenland now Off the
Bench through to the point man forsling
there's the shot score they had traffic
out in front and the Panthers have tied it at
one I think it's going to be Chuck E Cheese's
goal Matthew kachuck I believe got a stick on
it and gusta foring look at stenin L let a go
now look at this right in front and there's the
deflection I believe it went off the skate watch
the skate here of kachuck whether it hit his
stick before that but there was definitely a
redirection off the skate of kachuck Reinhardt
and barkov with him reinhardt's got it against
bear puts it out in front tipped away barari
was back skating with Rodriguez Panthers force
a turnover Rodriguez moving in shooting he
scores Evan Rodriguez gives the Panthers the
lead costly giveaway for the Washington Capitals
here's the capitals look at the play at the Blue
Line monter keeps it alive everybody on the white
jerseys are blown out of the Zone Rodriguez just
picks it up now he's got room Waits waits
till the last second to make sure he gets
an unmolested shot away and then then it's
skill versus skill and he just bar Downs it
what a beautiful goal the play was offside
we have no goal so we remain 1-1 they put
that time I think goie I think they they they
got it right from that angle that we saw right
there that puck was clearly over the Blue Line
here's Veri with it round for kachu he's got the
panther goal tonight marov kachuck in front
rard stopped oh that one hit the post catch
those penalty Killers just standing still bark
off he just throws it down to kachuck and it's
right there that's the sweet spot that you want
Reinhardt to take that shot right off kachuck was
driving kachuck at Center stolen away by protus
centering feed put out in front they score on a
deflection and mantha gives the capitals the lead
lead two to one oh we've seen this so many times
for the Florida Panthers totally dominated
and the capitals that only had two not very
good shots stripped to the puck right here and
here come the capitals and a beautifully timed
play mantha just sticks his stick out it goes
over top of the glove of boski and that one is
right barred down as well the man you want
the the puck on the stick and there's the
dishers kachu penalty to number 43 Tom Wilson
2 minutes for elbow the penalty 1720 of the
second up high toach elow he'll shoot score to
fli it in Mr power play Sam Reinhardt it's a
two2 game back on the point Panthers a little
out of position that's okay kachuck walks the
line he sees Reinhardt right there and look at
the hand eye coordination he tips it perfectly
straight down for a power play goal to top by
the game his 21st power play goal for Sam I Am
Reinhardt they're looking to chip in offensively
emman Larson pressuring staros a good hit cousins
gives to londell the shot blocked in front
here's Ean Larson and keer makes the save
stay in there on the offensive play there's
the shot deflection and Ekman Larsson found
Puck on a stick unfortunately he's on his back
hand look at how he just cuts out into the high
slot picks it up and he eblad digs it free lays
it down low for gich gagich to the front of the
net the backand knocked away stenin shot is
plucked at the net it comes to forsing up high
there's the rer that's blocked as well stenland
line great shift forsling holds in here's gadit
for forsling in the [__] save rebound settling
couldn't knock it out of the [Applause] [Music]
air poring holds sorts it out gich out in front of
the net they get it there but it goes wide looking
for a lane he shoots save made by keer rebound
oh St just missed keer got a piece of it went
right through him it's kulakov in front of lber
score the Lamborghini is loose it's 32 Florida
keeping their feet moving look at kulakov cool
as a cucumber puts it right in that high slot
onto the Stick of lomberg and he is waiting for
it look at that shot right over the glove of keer
and the reaction of Ryan lomberg finally that
line breaks through and now scoring him through
3 to one here comes Matthew kacha bet it goes
to the net there's the feed benett stopped by
keer kulakov trying to get there it rolls around
mantha chased by kachu kachu the takeaway kachuck
to Center empty net and to lerin and Bingo and
it's a 42 Panther [Music] [Applause] [Music]
lead so many times it's the hard work late
in the games and the little plays and the
Panthers are Masters at it protecting the
lead come out of their own end and there's
kachuck weaving through the neutral zone
draws a capital to him and just lays it
over to lyster in for the final seconds
kulakov who set up the game winner dumps
it down the ice and the Panthers get the win
the rats fly 4 to the final and Paul Maurice